Speaker 1: Listen, I want to keep talking
about the Twitter files.
I know that many of you are following the
Twitter files.
And I also want to make very clear what it
is.
It's right wing bait.
That's what it is.
It's meant to get people who don't really
know what's going on or who don't actually
read the Twitter files threads or who simply
are looking for something to be outraged.
About to be outraged and to say we all the
stuff that we said was happening was happening
and people need to go to jail or something
bad needs to happen.
So let's take a step back.
We have now seen at least three releases of
the Twitter files.
The Twitter files are supposedly exclusive
stories given to Matt Taibbi and Bari Weiss
to tweet about exposing everything that happened
at Twitter.
And it turns out that really not that much
happened.
For example, we learned that there was an
effort being made in 2020 by the Biden campaign
to have explicit images of Hunter Biden removed
from the platform.
Now, they were nude, explicit images of Hunter
published without his consent.
That's not allowed on Twitter per their own
terms of service.
And it's also against the law in most states
to publish such images.
And it was framed by some on the right as
the Biden administration is censoring content
on Twitter.
Well, there was no Biden administration at
the time, so crossed that piece off.
And they're not really censoring anything.
They're asking that content in violation of
Twitter's own policies be removed.
It wasn't really a bombshell as the Twitter
files have continued coming out, more and
more clear thinking individuals have realized
what many of us realized pretty quickly.
Charlie Wurtzel writes about this in The Atlantic
in an article I encourage you to read called
Elon Musk's Twitter Files Are Bait.
He doesn't actually want transparency on the
social media platform.
And this is, of course, absolutely correct.
The Twitter files expose no crimes that that
are clearly related to the actions Twitter
took.
I'm going to get to perjury in a second, and
I have no interest in hiding anything from
you.
The emails I get, David, you're hiding this
and that.
I'm just a guy in a room with a microphone.
I'm not hiding anything.
We'll get to perjury.
But the Twitter files expose no crimes with
regard to Twitter's actions, and they don't
even expose violations of Twitter's own terms
of service.
Twitter's own terms of service, if you want
to read them, include a process for communicating
content.
That content is violating Twitter's terms
of service.
It includes these very general catch that
these social media platforms can, at the end
of the day, decide to moderate content however
the hell they want.
As long as they're not doing something like
saying we don't allow Christians to post,
that would be against the law.
But beyond that, all of these platforms can
do this and it's in their terms of service.
Now, you can say you disagree with it, okay,
but it's in their terms of service.
So the point here is the Twitter files expose
no crimes and no violations of Twitter's own
terms of service.
They are intended to play to the right wing
persecution complex.
We're being censored.
We're being silenced.
We're not allowed to give the alternative
perspectives on COVID or on drinking urine
neuron, whatever it is that they want to do.
When private businesses tell you, Here's what
we're doing in our terms of service and you
accept and then they do it, there isn't very
much to talk about.
At worst, what we're learning is something
we knew, which is Twitter does what Fox News
does, right.
If you want to accept the most heavy argument
that could be made, which I don't believe
is actually defensible based on it, but what
would be Twitter is crafting a partizan message,
a message in through their moderation and
decisions.
Well, that's what Fox News does, the difference
being.
Twitter is a platform on which everybody gets
to post, at least in principle.
Fox News is broadcasting out one way no connection
between the Biden campaign and the suspension
of Donald Trump on Twitter, which was a big
thing that they had their hopes very high
for.
The most interesting part out of all of this
to me is the part of the files that say the
Trump administration not campaign apparently
had the exact type of access to Twitter moderation,
meaning they had email addresses, they could
email.
So part of the controversy is that the Biden
campaign, rather than reporting tweets, the
way you and I have to had email addresses
of people at Twitter that they could email
and say, hey, take a look at this.
Take a look at that.
You could argue that that's wrong.
You could argue the Biden campaign should
have had to use the same system we all have
to use to report tweets.
Fine.
But the Twitter files also say that the Trump
administration had the very same email access.
Conservatives are silent about that part.
Okay.
Let's now talk about maybe maybe the one part
that maybe is something.
And I'm getting emails from people saying,
David, you won't talk about this.
Listen up, folks, buckle in because I'm talking
about it.
The one thing I can maybe find that that would
be under the route, the umbrella of what we
would call criminal, is that there are now
allegations that Jack Dorsey perjured himself,
former CEO of Twitter, one of the instrumental
early people, Jack Dorsey said to Congress
under oath.
Twitter isn't shadow banning people.
According to the Twitter files, Twitter was
shadow banning people, and thus that is perjury
because Jack lied under oath.
Let's take a look at the clip from that hearing
years ago.
Speaker 3: I want to read a few quotes about
Twitter's practices, and I just want you to
tell me if they're true or not.
Please.
Social media is being rigged to censor conservatives.
Is that true of Twitter?
No.
I don't know what Twitter is up to.
It sure looks like to me that they're censoring
people and they ought to stop it.
Are you censoring people?
No.
Twitter Shadow Banning Prominent Republicans.
Speaker 2: Bad.
Is that true?
No.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So Jack Dorsey said we are not shadow banning
people.
And it appears based on some of the stuff
that's been released that that Twitter was.
So listen very carefully here.
If Jack Dorsey perjured himself and you can
prove it, throw the book at him, prosecute
him, do it.
I don't care if you can prove that the shadow
banned screenshots released in the Twitter
files are real and that Jack Dorsey knew that
there was shadow banning going on when he
testified.
Right?
Because that's part of it.
Perjury.
Did you know that you were telling a lie?
If you can prove those two points, then go
ahead and prosecute him.
I do want to remind you, however, Republicans
spent three years during the Mueller probe
saying lying to Congress and lying to the
FBI, that's all you can get.
What about the underlying crimes?
What about the collusion with Russia?
What about this, that or the other thing?
Financial crimes.
All you've got is lying under oath.
That's the only thing that's politically targeted.
Those when all you have is lying.
Those are politically targeted prosecutions
of Trump people.
We shouldn't even be worried about that.
Well.
If you were saying that during the Mueller
probe, then maybe you should be saying the
same thing here.
Notice I'm not saying that.
I'm saying if he perjured himself, go after
him.
It doesn't relate to the type of criminality
that they've been alleging.
Twitter engaged in.
This is just a guy who maybe lied.
Go after him for it, by all means.
But remember that you all were the ones saying
during the Mueller probe, when all you've
got is lying, you know, you've really
got nothing.